They didn't start this is mr.
Hugh dunn who worked as
a riveter on the sydney harbour bridge for
dorman and long back in in the twenties
when the bridge was being built. Will you
tell us about those times which today.
What would you like you know what could
you tell us first about the process of
riveting up on the arch. Well i'll
say this much. It was as good
a job as is ever been on your wonderful
stagings were beautiful suited you lovely.
And i was very happy. He was going to bridge
but that's one thing it struck me very
polished think about it too was when i got
the job first. I got the squad together
and the tools and by this
time the panel that was
a six panels. And the go on
the launch. That it is
actually what they call
a working punk kids come down and got
here in the cage. And that we went
and as we went up and sydney ferries were
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and i thought crash i'm never going to stop.
But as soon as i stepped on the court
. I lost my fear and that no more
fear from that day on it was
a really terrific job. My
hold up the fellow was
a hold up. When there was another
piece of the bridge. Coming up.
Like
a temporary light inside the court the
court going to use to waggle around and
never ever week. My whole access. Daddy as
a call on the bus regularly usually asking.
Daddy who is going to be safe enough.
You know i never had a moment's
fear that's honest. But got
a wonderful film to work for. And you
are partly a scottish firm as well as
a middlesbrough one weren't they not. I
know is that true. I mean as well along
also had
a steel mill in another. Well there's
something i didn't know but there would i
tell you what they were good they were very
good machines were good. All right. The
list. It was the best deal you can to
get ever get and. Well i had to be
first class when you put you out of it.
So i'm. Inspector humor long tested them.
At least had to come up again and then and
tell you that but whatever it was was
perfect. It was really good. Can you
describe for the listeners. The process of
riveting because riveting is long gone.
You know welding is taken over and people
don't know about it these days. Can you
just describe the process from the from the
looker on through. Well-aired
their oil fires and. That
these. Blow pipe and the cooker
would burst blood pretty well
just under the weight. You know and it was
shut them up to hold it up was that in
a compressed air line. Yes and hold it
up within that have it in a hole and put
a machine on it. And i would not give it
up. You know they all say that there live
. It down. What exactly do you mean by not
believe it then it came out of the hole
a vote or two in a quite
wrenches. And you had
a snap on your machine and you
compress it down. It made
a nice glow and you know i think it is
a solid conservative really. It's funny
that people have difficulty describing that
and we have you know many years later have
difficulty visible i think it. Can you
remember the you mentioned rigor. They used
to call daddy on the on the south side
was he the foreman regular was his no
proper name so i said yes. No i don't know
its name was it. That's all i can remember
is everybody column daddy. You know jack
harris then you. Yes he was on the other
side. Yes he was an outside light harris's
. I've also heard him called the
little man with a big mouth and i used
a girl in the human fly. What he
was capable man. Very careful man.
But you don't know that the bloke's name
these tickled that he was the rigger can
save the little fellow but my god he was
good not tell you something happened to
their stedding like the card was too. And
when it came up then up to strap covered
eyes to back and it was
a steady maintained for
a spell it out of it. And it
would finish this particular end
and they were going to swing the staging
ground to the next one and the two regular
said daddy will write it round.
She's not you want. Come on off
so they came off. Daddy went to the
green they would it matter. Right.
Next thing the stage in break down and the
water the lost control of the drum in
the top way you know it stagings
it funny pranks ever inch and
a half. So it was smashed
up so that he would.
Hear. Can you remember any accidents
working on the bridge. Yes. In fact i was
working on
a job. On i was on the opera house set at
the bridge and that's fellow vic kelly.
He was in the same job as me and others
say it. And i didn't see him fall
actually back so i'm just when
he went into the water. You know
that i mentioned before there was
a these working puns. Well there was one
from associate and one cannot state and
maintain that bridge was getting pretty
well over. If kelly it a felony mining it
a fellow know one of these
that work in punk from
a shop but it was gone he fell in
the water and i saw him come up and
doing a bit of breaststroke and of fell
a dive down for them and he oblivious
said oh look my back's gone.
Kelly lived. He just died about
a few months ago. Kelly. There's another
fellow. I didn't see that but he
he was screwing up. And if you don't like
it. He was screwing up both in the spine
i slipped over the side and he
burst and i didn't find out for
a few that. Yes i don't i have a
first hand account of that from
a stand london who was his
boilermaker. That how to stand
london this is alive he lives up in
merriweather in newcastle. Because he's blind.
I think he might be down at the celebrations
next week. And we had to cancel
have a little bit of
a reunion out of if you want to go. Noble
get another one and then ten from the men
noticeable cause you know but don't.
Yes. Do you remember any other accidents
and i mean as you know if you kill
rainier. Yes about there were sixteen died
although they weren't exactly killed
you know there's two down the quarry
a couple in the workshops on the pylons to
on the arch one knows two on the chance
. Although when he one fell off and died
one fell off and live to you know. And
there was one who was killed
on the deck level with
a plate that came down cut his leg.
But that fellow yes but there's
a plank somewhere under british tell me
of the sky was it died. What i just said
their names i've researched how they died
and it's in my book that i've written
actually do you remember any im using
incidents up on the art. Well. I
don't know well i'll tell you
i may as well tell you it was
a long way up. You know.
And if you want to go for
a toilet. Shut the rights
to the fact you got back.
You didn't obey any other hold up. I
mean he did what he got in the bag
and you folded up cereal and this is
a fluid over and up like that. And it went
round and round and round and straight
on the top deck of
a fairly often wonder what
that. Yes there was. Tom evans
who's
a regular tell me same story only it
landed right in the feet of. Well and knew
on the deck. That's quite possible but you
weren't bowman and where you want to lie
. You weren't bombing the engineers were
you. No no no no. Pretty good especially
when it was quite
a national. Can you tell us more about the
engineers and can you tell us more about
the engineers who worked on
the job. I remember hipwell
yes i remember where well in fact when
i got the job he said to me. Well you
fellows you know you come along and when
we get on the job he says you can do
a name of
a job we get you know and i said what
i'll tell you what i'll do you give me
a job and if i'm not suitable you come
and tell me and i walk or she is. That's
fair enough. That's how i got the job.
Where did you serve your time. John
brennan's and played bank scotland and
when did you come to australia. I came out
here to 1923. I was in
victoria for when it's over.
And that's when i come over to the new south
will. And by the way i saw you working
on the sydney aba bridge and got a job
on the story bridge up in queensland. As
a first couple of years. What sort of
comparison was there between the work on this
standard
a work on the sydney harbour bridge and the
story bridge. We could in fact what in
the shop for evans dickens and.
The stand that it was very good
very very good indeed all the plates
were whitewashed in scribd and
just had to be you know so so you
know what they do you know on
a segment of sydney
a bit but it's what they do it's
symbolises the job on the show and
assemble an expert yet to be sort of the
one that gets up in the talk. There's no
trouble. You know you only allowed six and
challenging the votes. Do you remember
what it was like riveting upside down the
cover plate along the chords. Yes as
a pretty thing you mention that.
Whole time and what their job.
Do and up one revis as you call them
wanted one to come out on never said maybe
even don't hand yet more levity
coming up and should be but
exactly how did you do. Do it when you doing
up and riveting. That's why it was one
of the staging before it was just whoever
designed it knew what he was doing.
If you look that of us from the me you
were set and then like you would have it
coming through you. You drew it up. It was
really good. And that's changing with
just right. Just you could just get that
you know as i've said i've ever comes out
of it too you know our plans are to unicorn
and shoot if you just enough momentum
to. Enough leverage to get up. There
must be pretty hard work. Oh yes it was
hard but how many rivets.
Would you drive up in
a shift or you will see
a vote or hell you didn't
say about sixty it was all
a little bit you know
what an inch and a nation
a quarter they were big rivers.
As big a division never
a joy of did you ever go in the
chords. In the court most of the time
a funny thing was. When the
come up and then the bus
will have it john. And that's what i
mostly did and i mean inside the court you
know you hold up was in there was any ben
inside the chords. Yeah well they caught
us and three on the to a stage i was
a sad bush you know both sides but then
on the come at the center i was inside.
Yes. So what was it like in the
good. Yes it was great it was
a. As i say you were under way to
late. You know hot. Not really cold
in winter and summer time yes that's
another thing too in the winter time you
mentioned just now know when we went up.
Number one thing it was foggy is how
you see the ferries here the fairies and
down below and then up to the qualia right
above the fog and they shun sheen
and fog which is level as could be
if it's essentially someone good up to all
of that i made of an hour. Certainly but
that you wouldn't believe the fog was level
you know what the trouble is i've seen
that in the country areas where you get
it. See just the tops of trees coming out
of it what it looks like
a lake. Just see the aeroplanes come up
through the fog and flying along the top.
Serving of china. I was
sorry when i get put off
a damn job. You married in those days.
Yeah i got married when i was young that i
got married meant in theory.
Yeah i get my do they take up
a collection for you when you got married.
No they did not. But some of the some of
the people say that they got to goodness
knows how much money out of it or
a clock or something. Now like it. Nothing
i don't know why i'd get nothing. I kept
it to quite
a set point i didn't tell anyone i told
was the squad i didn't tell them it was
just that i got married at newcastle
about it and. Where did you live at that
time. How did you get to work. I lived
in sydney. And i used to go down and use
a long she's to take the side in the
same night and coming back here.
When i get put off there was the money
wasn't coming from the governor not was it
depression times you know and the money
wasn't coming forward and it was a hell of
a big pay or corrupted and
coming to us. Both you know
sydney again the lines. I was on the job
says well done on sort of allusion here. I
said and i'm sorry to see weeks and weeks
of work ahead of me. She's not my work.
So my money is going to be you mean you'll
get back on again and i never got back
on again never got me so what happened here.
So what happened here. Were you on the
dole. Yes i was doing. Yes. Coupons.
Was it coupons in those days. Yeah
coupons us. Yeah so what did
you different. Oh well.
A fellow clean windows me to
get with him when he used
a payment and so i think. There
were tough times. I'll tell you
a very tough times. He remember other
things about those times you were married
then. Weren't you. Yes. Where
did you get your dole or
did you just you got the coupons or did
you pick it up in kind. No pins and you
just only got fifteen bob. And yes
very poor different you know it is i
can get through alright here. Did you get
money for cooking. You know for the meter
. To cook your food. Oh i certainly got
their coupons or so and they made it that
we couldn't get cigarettes through through
the thing and some people did you know
but it was tough times. I'll tell you do
you remember the dole inspectors. Yes and
fight one of their children specters
somebody don't mean do you. And that's yet
doing this cleanly infallible for this
fella and he's waiting for me and
that was
a really satisfying that. Is specter was
quite satisfied that i was doing was all
right. And we had to do
something in them days what was
a vent now fifteen but what
it. Those fifteen vibe
a week. You got for dolan fifteen but week
is well you know if you couldn't use you
coupons for rent. Could you. Oh no no no
no not yet do you find your rent somewhere
where you find it. Yes. Do you use state
in sydney all that time or did you take to
the track at all. I know i know my status.
I am freaked out after that i got
a job through that been able
to do that. I got a job in
a kind of street in sydney as a
cleaner and what was there for
a while. And that's what i went up to
do that.
I made out vacation forever
stations and i got
a job. I swear went up there so that was
the next job you got in your trade when
was that what year was that six from terry
one if that issue and was hand. I mean
that he had no you can look back on it
because someone was younger than he could
but a lot of things are you
know get a dollar here
a quid there somewhere someone to keep
things going. Do you remember the working
conditions generally on the bridge. You
know the answer. There was terrific
wonderful film to work and everything
was machines were good. Everything was
fostered out and the in the mess i said
the material it was everything was up to
you know. In fact it's
the best job ever. What
a life. Jevon you ever see or have anything
to do with conversation with ennis or
bad feel now. And he wouldn't maybe.
Another facet of it. Do you member
anything union activity on the job.
No not really of us. But the good fun as
it was concerned the money was good. You
know them days used to get.
When what would you guess
a long way to go back is
to get nine prior and
up till the planning and then from there.
Finally you get ten point fifteen when i
was good money there were days when the
boilermakers job an hour lunch out would be
about £5. I was good to see the
lady who used to work in the pay
offices one of those is still alive and
the other day she was one of the blokes
there reckoned that he got short paid one
and threepence on his last pay and he was
on about it so long that she getting twenty
cents. She did. I did at that frank go
there. I did and i said now the bit where
i tell you put the right of abilities you
call it. And i hit it and said it and that
diddler hit my finger and that ball and
now it's split and it's course
like that. So there's not so
could you explain that what you just said
to take the what of what tool to do you
use to take the birr office it off
their whole planet. I was just
a tool you put in the hall and i just
wanted the. Any level. Ray which is on
the book as you call it. Do you member any
rivets being cut out and the way you cut
them out. Yes. I cut plenty
a hitch. But tell you now.
No you. As i said and spent
a long and tested job made of then you get
a chip machine machine and these
tools to cut that have it if you cut
that about it and punch it out nude of
a chain. Along came inspect it again. He
would test again. Had to be right before
he left would let you go to is all they
were terrific and that you couldn't
material that if it was slack it was just
a gesture. They used to hammer them and
hold them with their fingers and say if it
was not
a river rattle it spittle very small little
hammer hit them one way and then it hit
the back of the lists least genitalia
to him. So that reg is tight
as a tail what i think
a theme in ten. But you really should do.
I mean paint it well enough but should
last forever because the
bessa but is still best
a steel. You were at the schwinn when
it was joined where you. Yes yes i was
at when it joined yes. Would you let you
know whether. Well you were actually up
there the night it was joined or we up
around about that time. Well
what i know about it was on
that day was they got result except on the
generals and they took fort as it was
as a frenchman took for us it's
a funny thing. This man. It made
a book but all about the bridge are any
malard i think as his name too. Although so
one. Photo
a book i've seen that
wasn't them was enough. So
that's the only time i get my foot it taken
as i was gently before the usually in
the court. But i put a
wise one time was that
a sane one so people up there
taking photos and that was
a noise. I never get my
foot. It's funny but. Up on
that bridge well. That that it wet and
the weather. You know the weather with
played
a part you know but it was joined at night
because i wasn't there then when you
manage getting here can where you know
if you were out there. Do you get
a sovereign or
a camera to bulb it to bob. So i go and
fight might be around somewhere yet i've
got some things and now i might
be there. Yet you've got to has
a metal. I wish i never was for all four
i didn't intentionally do it. I just
happen when i get paid
off. I happen to have
a pocket have it neck and some ice around
somewhere so that was the timekeepers
metal so i used it. Yeah it when you went
up you pick what you pick the metal up my
was for that was that as
security thing as well as being
a timekeepers thing i know i don't think
so now you know i don't know if there's
a version or scares. Nothing there that you
just hang your medal up by that by the
clock when you came back we pick it up and
then you turn your puter back any you
know if you lunchtime you could have had
can't remember that i know at night time
you put it back any that was current
for here now you're off the job. And i
heard you can you member of the other
momentos you might have had from the bridge
like rivets you didn't give any of them to
know i'll tell you. So my doctor just up
was talking to doctors
cuddy. His son gave him
a book on the bridge and another
patient. It was telling this
this other fellow about it and it shows
you that you get to your patients here we
don't need is he. What can anybody birds.
So when i went up there born there but.
Well i had books. Like hardcover
things but self one about the bridge.
He said he was taking
a big interest an average. So i gave them
to him. So you might even get someone
over him. A telfair yes i know dr.
Carey it's
a i've got plenty of documentary evidence
all i wear on about people's reminiscences
now i see. Well things that you can
remember that nobody else would know. Well
that's pretty well covered. Although some
things come up. I'm down. Whole bit.